Hey Youtubers, it's Charlie.
This is going to be my Flash of Two Worlds
video.
There is a whole bunch of stuff to explain,
so as I get through top moments I'll try to
explain the Multiverse, what the TV show is
doing with that and some of the new characters
really like the whole purpose of this episode
is just to put Jay Garrick on team flash and
establish him as a mentor for Barry this season
and will quick reminder new round of the giveaway
starts now I'm giving away a reverse flash
ring all you have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video so just
careful for spoilers in the episode if you
haven't seen it yet and I know some of you
were watching in a gap preempted by baseball
or something Simon had to go back and watch
that the first seven minutes here we go number
five Jay Garrick explains zoom what he said
is is that zoom first showed up about the
same time he got his powers on earth two which
is about two years ago so he's really only
been the flash about a year longer than Barry's
been the flash and he lost his powers the
minute the wormhole opened and sucked them
in so he didn't say zoom stole his speed he
just says he doesn't know how he lost that
zoom was trying to kill him he wants to be
the only flash on in the world so it sounds
like zoom is just crossing over into other
universes trying to kill all the flashes they
were really clear that zoom was from earth
two so he could be from a different earth
but he's basically just working his way all
over the multi-verse trying to kill the other
flashes Jay said that zoom wants to be the
best so just remember that I think the language
that they wrote in there is actually enemy
important to figuring out who zoom is eventually
zoom as that line in the comic con trailer
where he said he rose die so he doesn't want
to be a hero he just wants to be the best
on the number for me zoom voice by Tony Todd
we finally get to see him full on and we get
to hear the voice amelia we heard in the trailer,
but but this time it was just a much more
plonk scene this here is what it looks like
when someone crosses between Earth there's
still a whole lot we don't know about jumping
back and forth between Earth one and earth
to may be just the flashes can do it maybe
it has something to do with being at the specific
pockets of energy for now I'm just going to
assume that the only people to go back and
forth are zoom in Barry just because they
have speed force powers Martin Stein filling
in with Cisco is slowly figuring things out
and then there both slowly County going crazy
and in slightly different ways so on the number
three Martin Stein figures out what's going
on with Cisco the line the Cisco had was I
get a vibe then I see a vision of something
that's happened in then it goes away that
all the visions have been to people that are
from earth two so he's just sensing the alternate
reality like the alternate energy that's being
given off by these people I was actually a
little surprised that Cisco's reaction the
fact that he didn't want to tell people that
the reason he explains is because Harrison
wells made it seem like he was really special
he taught you know you have this great destiny
ahead of you and he turned out to be super
evil so Cisco is getting a very sinister quote
unquote vibe from his abilities he just he
doesn't trust it at all so he does want to
tell everyone because he's not sure how to
deal with it yet do not be surprised if the
same thing happens with Caitlin snow hopefully
will be the exact same thing because she also
has metahuman abilities the show just hasn't
explored that yet if we've learned anything
from genre shows is that when a character
gets a special ability and hides it from all
of his friends it never ends well on the flipside
of that Martin Stein looks like he's slowly
losing his mind and there is a little bit
of silly set up like oh I'm never going to
be merging with anyone else like you to he
and a couple lines of dialogue that made it
seem like he was never going to fuses firestorm
course we know that's totally not true sometimes
when you see setups like this you like okay
there very clearly setting this up for the
twisted surprise surprise he's going to merge
with another firestorm he of the writers a
little bit of a pass just because the writing
that for people that do not read comics on
the number to meet Patty Spivot newest member
of Joe's task force and probably future member
of team flash does anybody want to lay bets
now on how long it's going to take her to
figure out the barriers the flash I've been
seeing like two or three episodes maybe faster
than that maybe it will take longer I meet
him he will see most of her storyline and
most of her interaction with Barry is gonna
take place at the police station when he is
not the flash if you like both Jay and Patty
had a great introductions this season like
the setup for their character was a really
well thought out like they're not just out
for revenge they have tragedy in their past
that they're trying to work past her trying
to move forward which was kind of the theme
of the first episode their highly skilled
they want to help people do not like completely
shackled by their emotions so I'll be really
happy that Patty isn't going to be like dragging
her baggage around all season long but it
is interesting to note that weather wizard
at least in the TV show killed her father
before he got his powers when he was just
a normal bank robber was after he and his
brother got superpowers that Patty was like
this is terrible evil people were getting
superpowers and no one will be able to stop
them from hurting everyone I need to do something
about this so that that that was her big called
action the other big thing that's going to
be happening with her character on the show
is that she's being brought in as a potential
love interest for Barry's character like that
that was part of her character description
when they Cast her so if you read into some
of the dialogue that she has about kismet
and fate then you know that's kind of the
direction that's headed but that also kinda
speaks to her comic book history is a speedster
she got speed force powers on two different
occasions one like the way way back in the
comics when she first debuted she became what
was known as Ms. flash that she really didn't
show up a whole lot I told Geoff John's broader
back during his Wally West run and she became
like like a person at the police station during
that run instead of being just a regular police
officer or detective like she's gonna be on
the show she was a forensic scientist just
like Barry Finn during the new 52 they they
put her in Barry and this like ongoing relationship
and in that version of events he wasn't going
out with Iris he wasn't married to her anything
like that live in a number different versions
of her character but the producers brought
her in the season just going to be able to
match that Barry level of energy that relate
excitable nerd energy that he has speaking
of which when they're not hurting out here
together watching the interrogation they were
talking about Monty Python's holy Grail that
they that was the reference she was talking
about the troll on the bridge course for me
on my number one meet Jay Garrick the Crimson
Comet so really important here there been
a couple changes to Jay Garrick from the comics
you can see right away already he made this
big deal about how he used to be a scientist
part-time scientist part-time superhero but
I guess I guess the super partisan around
anymore really you can see this coming a mile
away there just are trying to build chemistry
between those two characters they both lost
a really important part of themselves they're
going to bond over that and help each other
heal Jay lost his speed Caitlin lost Ronnie
so there there both going to rebuild their
shattered emotions together I'm not really
expecting anything crazy on that relationship
and remember it's been six months since Ronnie's
dive so she is slowly going to be rebuilding
her life throughout the rest of the season
over the most part Jay Garrick's job at star
labs of earth two from from his world is pretty
similar to what Caitlin doesn't star labs
in this world so their relationship is kind
of a mirror of what's going on with Patty
and Barry it just did Patty does not know
that Barry is the flash yet I think Joe giant
yet it was a little confusing early on why
Barry was trying to shut him down when they
when they first met you know you just you
wouldn't believe anything he said the big
speech with Iris just explained that he just
doesn't want to trust anyone anymore that
the ghetto Batman mode I'm not even going
to trust my friends so again Iris has to be
the voice of reason telling him your your
friends believing you you need to believe
in them or else derogative bolt the whole
reason they did this is because they want
to let you know that Jay Garrick is not an
evil character he is exactly who he says he
is not gonna turn into another both in the
henhouse like Harrison wells was just explained
that twisted the end to Harrison wells the
showed up at the end that's on earth two earth
to Harrison wells will be a thing the season
Tom Cavanagh is still a series regular let
me know in the comments though is your favorite
moment was it Barry learning how to throw
lightning throw speed force lightning that's
what he was doing or was it just meeting the
new characters Jay Garrick and Patty Spivot
this episode probably gonna go down as one
of my favorites in season I mean remember
there's 23 totals there's still a lot more
left to come and I almost forgot about the
big twist at the end Iris his mother shows
up so we'll find out what went on between
her and Joe and how Wally West is going to
fit into that equation is really like a knee-jerk
WTF at the end so it will have to wait till
next week to really find out what's going
on with that to get some actual scenes with
them soulfully of explain some of the new
comic book characters some the new concepts
in on this and there's 52 pockets of energy
that doesn't mean they're going to be visiting
52 verse it just means that there 52 places
in central city where there are breaches really
all that means is that you're just gonna see
metahuman's from Earth to start popping up
all over central city there were some moments
in the New York comic con trailer that did
not make it into this episode will post links
that in the description see you can see just
there's a little bit extra stuff tomorrow
is a new episode were going to meet anarchy
he's going to be a really big character in
season two will be like the small bad you
Damien Darhk big bad Anarky going to be the
small bad so white is with lots of the post
you can click here for the New York comic
con Flash and Arrow trailers like gentlemen
the one thing you can click here for this
week Gotham video just post a while ago thank
you so much for watching everybody high give
and I'll see you guys tomorrow!